[Musik]
herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen
video ich habe noch nie so ein fußball
nicht so aufregend wie macht man das am
besten welche ich hoffe natürlich wäre
es gut ich glaube heute zwei fußball
dadurch begegnen dass er leute sagen ihr
könnt euch damals gut vorstellen
ja wir sind im news stehen eher für die
für den frühstart für eine push
verfahren bleibt haben sich er heute
gegen alexis sanchez drin
leute wir drehen heute zwei videos 1
kommen bei denen auf dem kanal eins
kommt auf diesem kanal ist genau das was
ich tue und ich habe mir was wirklich
genial ist 1 verlassen ich habe ja schon
irgendwann meine fussball challenge
gemacht sie ist da habe ich gedacht okay
ich weiß nicht vielleicht war das nicht
so das ding machen wir das mit noch ein
bisschen mehr background so weiter also
wir sparen müssen hier genauso wie sein
und zwar habe ich insgesamt zwölf
lebensmittel gekauft die hengste im tor
und das spannende daran ist die hälfte
von denen schmeckt übels scheiße
wir haben gerade elf uhr morgens und die
andere hälfte ist halt lecker sind
süßigkeiten und so oft gehört info oben
rechts nach hinten fischt der hängt seit
45 nur jetzt könnt ihr euch forschen die
packen sich schon scheiße aus der
pflicht er gerade schön besonders
schädigt das wird wirklich ich muss
sagen ich kann euch gern mal die ganzen
lassen zeigen und dann strafen also
schenkte auf jeden fall auch irgendwie
ob es wird auch fast und du kannst
einmal kurz wir zeigen kannst
ja okay das reicht schon also ihr seht
ja das kann ich auch noch mehr leute das
ist heute unsere zweite kamera
ich zeige euch die ganzen lebensmittel
kommt damit wir fangen wir zum beispiel
an mit fisch dann haben wir hier so
chips hier ist ein nutzer du kannst du
einfach einmal durchgehen
wir haben wir chilisoße die haben wir so
nach gummi
das hier ist glaube ich das ekligste mit
dem tisch das sind einfach klopfer also
alkohol um 11 uhr morgens und das sind
die ekligsten klopfer die ich gefunden
habe
wir haben also vitamin c tabletten die
brauchen richtig im mund also langes
richtig ab schokoriegel klopfer das
kennt ihr auch schon wir haben wir noch
sojasauce hier ist tomatenketchup und
das hier sind so keine ahnung sharm el
loco bands wie auch immer ich habe ja
noch gar nicht die trainer nicht richtig
erklärt was mal auf wir schießen jetzt
gleich immer abwechselnd auf dieses
mittel auch wenn man eigentlich mit
lebensmitteln dass man sagt immer man
sollte niemals auf lebensmitteln
schießen mit lebensmitteln fifa nicht
dann lassen wir das
nein wir schießen abwechseln drauf und
natürlich ist es ja dein ziel was zu
treffen was lecker ist wenn du dann
wirklich etwas trips was lecker ist
musst du das einmal probieren also
einmal was von essen wenn du allerdings
was außen trist was nicht so lecker ist
musst du das auch probieren wenn du
nicht triffst musst du hier einmal neben
das tor gehen unsere trinkflasche für
heute genau hier haben wir eine
trinkflasche das ist halt dieses
zitronen dingen so als kleine bestrafung
einfach einmal kurz den mund eine
fußball jungs einmal durchspielen und ja
das ist die challenge ich würde sagen
mir lama nicht angefangen gerade mal 6
also wir starten jetzt bleibt auf jeden
fall dran am ende wird noch diese
ballverluste dabei haben die beiden
jungs organisiert den derbys tabelle
halten länger und frieden so leute
ich starte die ganze runde machen und
sagen gesprochen habe waren es erst mal
bisschen bisher ein möglicher
rechtlicher wünsche
roman haider zu singen
ich glaube eigentlich nicht würde aber
das war richtig was leider nichts
getroffen
deswegen muss rein square wie sagt man
ein spitzer da so richtig einfach kommt
ja das reicht völlig black ist einfach
hören waren heute als richtig bin ich
dran und ich gehe mal darauf diese
schokoriegel
da hängt zwar viele klopften warum aber
das ist mir egal weil ich kann rund um
die uhr laufen
also ich mein erster schuss also ganz
halle ich bin die linke seite ist
sympathischer trotz ketchup und
sojasauce lecker lecker lecker betont
unsere leute gelacht
ich bin wieder dran ist hier wieder auf
diese lions
ich hätte was ich glaube davon werden
die heute ein bisschen mehr trinken
er war doch keiner getroffen dass sie
das er ist ein glücksfall
das war der klopfer das war der klopfer
ja ja ja heute sagt prost
o
was ist der entschuldigung da ist ja
ganz schön oder leute die was ich dachte
okay
kräuter geschmack und ja ich bin wieder
dran tolle rot runter gespielt deswegen
sagen die schnur durchtrennt ja nein
auf dem zweiten club
ich bin die ganze zeit vor
[Applaus]
ja hier 11 glücklich
das liegt aber auch daran weil ich wegen
keine fußballschuhe anhat dann muss man
sich erst wieder zum wievielten mal
nämlich dort jetzt schon vier mal so
dass noch nie was anderes in alex ist
aber gar nicht so schlimm und einmal für
den geschmack bergwerk eher
unattraktiven linke seite geworden ist
heute fokus auf die lakonie
nichts passier leute die wollen nämlich
gern okay ich bin wieder dran
während eines dringend mache ich jetzt
ein labor
aber wenn ihr das schafft dann schoss
alex betrieben zusammen
[Musik]
leute ich komme jetzt ein trick ein
versprechen dass er geht
ja aber da sind die füße
das war richtig gut gemacht
gebracht sagte klopp
der richter habe heute wir haben kleines
problem dadurch dass der schuss der rest
ist teil dieses öffnungs klingen
abgeflogen und dann fliegt jetzt so
langsam rauf ein bisschen mehr noch ich
musste jetzt ist offenbar können ich
brauche zwei minuten soviel fokus haben
die community und 321 einmal so ablaufen
da kommt das zählt ich bin ja schwerlich
zu winterbild fokus ist da ich muss
sagen
das war nicht schlecht vor jungs
[Musik]
ich habe da eine belohnung kaputt
geschossen
ich bin ganz ehrlich mir gut direkt übel
ich musste auch hier kennt das man
rechnen muss einfach nur ich glaube der
fisch war nicht gut
also man hat den geschmack sofort
gemerkt haben ja jetzt gefühlte stunden
der sonne kann nur besser werden
der ganze hier ist hinterm zaun
zersplitterten künftig keine also da
kann jetzt auch nichts machen
rot-rot von uns gleich hoch
mann oder freund wie zitronat vielleicht
erstmals auf
[Musik]
ich bin echt nicht so begabt was du mir
kann nichts bringen aber so dass andere
das okay leute jeder noch einen schuss
okay ich habe noch zwei glaube ich auf
die teen witch den letzten schuss fast
richtig besonderes
[Musik]
der moment der das netz platzt ihr
letzter schuss von mir wollte ich jetzt
auch mal kurz vor hoch
sein
sie hatte packung fressen den bei dem es
zu gewinnen gab hat alex herumgeschossen
okay leute wir sind durch die hälfte der
lebensmittelhändler noch leicht auf
jeden fall das video bei denen ein
bisschen bestrahlung von links und
dieser job ist aber hier wird jetzt noch
verlust kommentiert einfach und
abonniert den kanal von dem abonniert
menschen auch und da haben wir dann ein
bisschen gewinner aus werde das
kontaktiert von euch genau alles klappt
auf jeden fall geistige gewesen und hat
das ganze bank dreht sich noch ein
bisschen amerika nicht für die kräuter
kohle die hatte ich schon in die luft